Guten Morgen Anne.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Aux
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 299 Jahr wir haben es tatsächlich noch geschafft rechtzeitig vor der 310 Sendung
auch noch diese Lücke zu schließen zumindest fangen wir jetzt gerade mal damit an und es ist wie sollte es anderes sein ein kleines Spezial und ich bin ihr schon gehört hab heute
gemeinsam mit Anne zusammen und gemeint ist Arne semsrott hallo Anne.
Guten Morgen.
Anne du bist unsere Hörerinnen und Hörer ja schon
gut bekannt denn du warst ja auch schon mal zu Gast und zwar bei unserer letzten großen live Sause unser Gala Logbuch Netzpolitik 256.
Im Babylon Berlin hätte ich habe gehört es gibt noch es gibt noch Tickets fürs nächste Jubiläum.
So siehts aus diesen Samstag geht's ja los über die sicherlich alles schon unsere Dauerwerbesendung gehört haben wir danach ist auch ist auch,
na aber wir müssen natürlich alle kommen Harvey falls du es denn damals hast du das kannst du das irgendwie Sport.
Super ja ich war ja am Ende da ich glaube ich sollte ihr habt mich irgendwie hin bestellt für 18 Uhr und dann war ich dran gegen 23 Uhr oder so das war ein.
Hat sich bisher gezogen.
Aber weil du weißt was schön war schön von beiden Seiten im Publikum und auf der Bühne.
Ja genau das da dafür dass es sich diesmal nicht ganz so mega zieht mit den Gästen alles war immer ein bisschen brutal bei 4 Teilnehmern im ist immer so fängst halt einzuplanen dann denkst du so naja,
wenn ich da so jeder 10 Minuten wenn es 15 Minuten werden und so und dann ist es alles etwas interessante Leute und eigentlich sagte die Podcast Erfahrung 15 Minuten das gerade mal die Begrüßung durch.
Naja dann zog sich das und zog sich das aber wir wussten was ableiten zu schießen deswegen bin ich.
Verdammt das war es okay her.
Nananana das ist mir wollte natürlich am Schluss mit alle Schüler meine Kleinen sind noch mal ein richtiges Highlight setzen dass uns auch glaube ich ganz gut gelungen,
nun gut genug Marmelade um den Mund geschmiert
wir wollten hier mal zusammen kommen weil du ja weiter Umtriebe ich unterwegs bist vielleicht kurz zur Erinnerung also Projekten wie frag
den Staat verklagt den Staat alles rund ums Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und was sich daraus in letzten Jahren so ein Konsequenzen geliefert hat bist du ja so Fang überhaupt nicht aufzuhalten weil du es ja auch nicht alleine bist weiß nicht wie viele Leute schwören mittlerweile
um deinen deinem.
Lade dir also was hatten Statue Stefan Wehrmeyer der der Gründer des Projekts,
auch weiterhin dabei und dann haben wir inzwischen eine Bufdi Stelle im Bundesfreiwilligendienst leistenden und ab Mai tatsächlich noch eine,
eine weitere Stelle die aber tatsächlich erstmal für den Volksentscheid Transparenzgesetz aushilft und wir versuchen so übers Jahr,
hätte ich mal so ein bisschen zu wachsen aber er geht sehr sehr langsam aber Melisa mehlig wenn ich spenden bei uns reinkommen funktioniert.
Liegt das nur an der finanziellen Unterfütterung oder ist es so dass ihr Schwierigkeiten habt da die passenden Leute zu finden oder.
Der tatsächlich die Finanzierung aus irgendeinem Grund kriegen wenn ich so eine gute öffentliche Finanzierung,
naja also geht die meisten also tatsächlich die meisten möglichen Geldgeber für sonnenprojekt die verklagen wir
so um Information und das macht natürlich ziemlich schwierig da überhaupt was zu holen wir sind gerade ein bisschen in Gesprächen mit Stiftung auch aber natürlich ist für so ein Projekt am besten wenn man direkt spenden bekommt und das
wird gerade immer besser da versuchen wir uns auch zu professionalisieren und per wenn wenn das steht dann können wir auch mehr Leute rein holen.
Erst müssen schwierig Napalm Ministerium anzuklopfen geht's wieder nach zu verknallt.
So jetzt hast du aber ein neues Projekt am Start wir gehen mir die Ideen offensichtlich nicht aus oder euch vielmehr.
Und zwar möchten wir heute sprechen über eine neue Initiative die ihr jetzt wie lange schon vorbereitet.
Partezettel schon seit zwei Jahren oder so das ist ein ziemlich am Marathon oder eher so ein Triathlon den wir da haben aber angefangen mit dem Gesetz zu schreiben haben wir glaube ich vor zwei Jahren.
Der alles geht um ein Transparenzgesetz für Berlin,
das hast du ja schon einige Erfahrungen mit Gesetzen sammeln können und um vielleicht mal dahin zu kommen wo ihr jetzt
Saitek ich mal vielleicht mal ganz wertvoll ein bisschen mal auf zu blättern was.
Eigentlich so angesetzten und Gesetzes Ideen
um einen transparenten start weil darum geht's ja letzten Endes herzustellen so eigentlich schon gibt man ihr reitet jetzt dieses Informationsfreiheitsgesetz Pferd schon eine ganze Weile.
Und sind formations preisgesetze sind ja jetzt in dem Sinne auch nichts neues oder.
Genau also es trug sich zu im Jahre 1766 tatsächlich das erste Informationsfreiheitsgesetzes ist weltweit.
Das ist jetzt 253 Jahre alt das kommt aus Schweden Schweden hatte so als erstes
Gesetze im 18 Jahrhundert gemacht dass zum einen die Zensur abgeschafft hat und zum anderen so den Grundsatz klargemacht hat die Infos sieht man im Staat liegen die
gehören den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und die müssen raus gegeben werden,
und auf das geht eigentlich all das hier zurück was wir machen allerdings muss man auch sagen nach Schweden kam erstmal nix und die die Welle der Informationsfreiheitsgesetze die es so gibt die fing dann wieder ein bisschen an vor,
53 Jahren mit den USA die haben den Freedom of Information Act gemacht ehrliches Gesetzen in den USA
gegen den Widerstand des Präsidenten damals Lyndon B Johnson der wollte eigentlich nicht unterschreiben hat er dann aber doch gemacht weil der Kongress dafür war
dann ging es ein bisschen weiter ich hier und da auf der Welt dann kam Großbritannien Tony Blair hat vor knapp 15 Jahren,
ein solches Gesetz eingeführt und hat im Nachhinein ganz interessant wenn man die Autobiographie von Tony Blair,
liest gesagt das war der größte Fehler seiner gesamten Amtszeit also nicht irgendwie der der Irakkrieg oder so nee nee das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz das war sein größter Fehler.
Hahaha du auch erklärt warum.
Ja weil es ihnen schwerer gemacht hat einfach so durch zu regieren weil auf einmal so diese
halt diese Journalisten und diese NGOs auf einmal gekommen sind und Informationen von ihm wollten und
das hat er natürlich auch zu vielen Skandalen geführt also gerade in Großbritannien und da gab es ja diese nix
Spencer scandal also den den großen Skandal vor ein paar Jahren wo raus kam das
wahnsinnig viele Abgeordnete des Parlaments Gelder veruntreut hatten also Gelder diese eigentlich zum zur Ausstattung ihrer Büros bekommen haben da haben die sich dann,
z.b. ihre Privathäuser irgendwie mit verschönert und so und das kam plötzlich raus angestoßen durch den Freedom of Information Act.
Und das war natürlich auch ein ziemlich großes Problem für viele labour Politiker.
Ja wie soll man denn da noch reagieren also das ha.
Wenn man auf einmal mit der Öffentlichkeit zu tun haben.
Ja mein Pool ist nicht fertig.
Fertig ich glaube es gab tatsächlich jemanden der hat sich ein so ein so ein Wal so ein Schutzwall vor sein Haus gebaut wie so eine alte Ritterburg also skurrile Geschichten anders.
Aber du denkst das nicht wirklich ne dass das eine eine Einschränkung die Regierungsfähigkeit immer dieses Argumentes
Kr vielleicht auch mal aufgreifen nur sagen ok ja wenn man sich die ganze Zeit über alles verantworten muss und wenn man sie überhaupt nicht mehr stillen Kämmerlein auch mal die durchziehen kann dann wird das ja alles noch schwieriger als es ohnehin schon ist.
Na ja es ist eine Einschränkung einer gewissen Art von Regierungs
Tätigkeit würde ich sagen also wenn man tatsächlich so eine Hinterzimmerpolitik macht die ganze Zeit und wenn man tatsächlich an der Öffentlichkeit vorbei,
etwas beschließen will und dann am Schluss sagen da hier das ist jetzt
bekommen und ihr habt nicht mitbekommen dann ist das natürlich tatsächlich eine Einschränkung von so einer Art von von Regierungen die Frage ist dann damit zusammenhängt was will man denn für eine Art von Regierung haben und so ein Informationsverhalten gesetzt oder,
daneben weiterhin Transparenzgesetz als Fortsetzung davon ist dann eher eine Art von Gesetz die einem hilft wenn man.
Offen regiert wenn man Leute mitnehmen will und wenn man vielleicht auch ein gewisses Interesse selbst hat an der kritischen Öffentlichkeit also da gibt es ja durchaus einige Beispiele dafür wie so etwas,
wieso eine Transparenz dann auch die ab.
Die Akzeptanz oder das Vertrauen der Öffentlichkeit in den bestimmte Art von regieren stärkt das heißt eigentlich kann Transparenz tatsächlich dabei helfen.
Wenn man denn die Öffentlichkeit mitnehmen will bei so so und dann haben wir jetzt Großbritannien und,
währenddessen während das so ein bisschen hier und da lief und während die USA dann im Rahmen ihrer Entwicklungszusammenarbeit angefangen hat
ins Ausland zu gehen und zu sagen ja übrigens ihr bekommt nur noch Gelder von uns in Zukunft wenn ihr auch ein Informationsfreiheitsgesetz einführt also die USA sind relativ stark auf andere Länder zugegangen haben gesagt jetzt macht ihr mal auch sonst kriegt er keine Gelder mehr von
von uns wären das so an Milch passierte Ende der 90er Jahre hat sich dann auch tatsächlich in in Deutschland endlich was,
m und die ersten Informationsfreiheitsgesetze die ist dann gab waren in Brandenburg und in Berlin 1998 und 99
auch kein Zufall dass es vor allem erstmal Ost Bundesländer waren die so im Gesetz eingeführt haben nämlich auch gerade Brandenburg wirklich explizit mit dem Bezug zur DDR Zeit und,
zu der Erfahrung dass private Leute eben all Ihre Daten offenlegen mussten oder zumindest befürchten mussten dass es offengelegt
wird und gleichzeitig der Start aber so wahnsinnig verschlossen ist und da hat Brandenburg als erster als erstes deutsches Bundesland gesagt nee wir wollen das in Zukunft anders haben wir wollen,
das eben auch der Staat sich öffnen muss.
Und das ging so ein bisschen dann durch die Bundesländer Berlin hat das auch übernommen bis dann tatsächlich 2005 auch der Bund gesagt hat ja ok
wir machen so ein EFG Sonnen Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auch auf Bundes.
Und ich glaube aber was interessant ist an diesem diesen Gesetzen ist das die,
einigermaßen skurril sind weil dann die Regierung jetzt erstmal so von von,
ihre Herangehensweise jetzt kein großes Interesse daran hat Informationen abzugeben weil das natürlich dann auch,
Kontrollverlust zumindest zu einem bestimmten Grad ist und da sieht man ganz gut auf Bundesebene da gab es nämlich
ewig Initiativen aus verschiedenen Richtungen Sony FG einzuführen 1998 ging es eigentlich los und erst 2005 gab's das letztlich aus dem Bundestag heraus also das ISG
ist ein sehr besonderes Gesetz weil es nicht geschrieben wurde vom Innenministerium oder einem anderen Ministerium sondern tatsächlich aus der Mitte des Parlaments von Abgeordneten herauskam und da würde mir jetzt das sächlich spontan kein anderes Gesetz einfallen bei denen das so war,
gewöhnlich ist es ja so dass innenminister er macht ein Entwurf dann geht's an die anderen Ministerien hat man Kabinettsentwurf dann geht's an den Bundestag aber hier war es tatsächlich andersrum das Innenministerium wollt sowas nicht machen
die sind nicht so ein großer Fan von Informationsfreiheit deswegen kam es aus dem Parlament heraus und das ist glaube ich ja.
Was heißt denn aus dem Parlament heraus also aus allen Fraktionen oder.
Na das waren vor allem rot grüne Politiker also verschiedene es gibt dann glaube ich jetzt unter den Vätern und Müttern Gesetzen bisschen Streit darüber wer jetzt der,
am meisten Vater am meisten runter ist wie das so ist aber das waren Politiker aus den Koalitionsfraktionen und letztlich unter,
wie nennt man das dann Tolerierung der FDP also die FDP hat dann dieses Gesetz setzt sich im Bundesrat mit durchgewunken und hat sich enthalten das waren so die Parteien die daran
mitgewirkt haben.
Weil ich ziemlich bemerkenswert bitte auch noch so ein anderes Gesetz was ich seit ein paar Jahrzehnten seiner Realisierung hardness gibt ja auch noch immer nach zieht nicht die Umsetzung der antikorruption Vorgaben aus Europa
die angehen Taschen aber nicht durchgesetzt.
Na also es gab zumindest
gott muss ich mich mal die 109e ist es glaube Strafgesetz wo es gibt zumindest so ein paar Verbesserungen die es in der letzten Legislatur dazu noch gab aber klar also wenn wir uns Dekorations und an die kautions Gesetzgebung anschauen da ist da ist Deutschland
seltsamerweise sehr sehr weit hinten im internationalen Vergleich.
Warum nur okay also seit 2005 gibt es jetzt Informationsfreiheitsgesetz auch auf Bundesebene und das war ja auch für Stefan und dich dann ein bisschen die Vorlage.
Genau weil.
Verein für Stefan als als Gründer des Projekts so die Erkenntnis nach ein paar Jahren da war ja es gibt dieses tolle Gesetz aber ein tolles Gesetz allein reicht ja offensichtlich nicht man braucht auch ein bisschen Kraft dahinter um dieses Gesetz zur Realität.
Fern zulassen und deswegen hat Stefan,
fragdenstaat.de programmiert also dieses Portal über das man einfach anfragen stellen kann nach dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und die Idee ist das sächlich dahinter vor allem.
Das was in der Theorie umgesetzt drin steht also Demokratie stärken Kontrolle des öffentlichen Handeln die Grundlage legen für Partizipation,
so umzusetzen dass die Informationen die einzelnen Leute bekommen dann auch direkt transparent öffentlich werden fahren.
Rate mal nachgeschaut wann das erste mal hier mit Stefan gesprochen haben das war im Januar 20122 auf dem Kongress aufm 28c drei haben die Interviews geführt und dann danach veröffentlicht das war so eine der allerersten
Logbuch Netzpolitik folgen wo frag den Staat das erste Mal.
Und Ärztin ist das nicht eröffnete lnp Öffentlichkeit gesehen hat das war ja oder auf dem Kongress vorgestellt et cetera pp.
Genau 2011 ist das.
7 Jahre Namen genau.
Von.
Ja okay also das ist sozusagen die Situation mit den Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in die gibt es die werden jetzt genutzt da kann man sicherlich mit Detail auch noch über die eine oder andere Verbesserung
nachdenken bleibst noch mal zum Abschluss dazu also in wie wie wie zufrieden seid ihr denn mit dem Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in der heutigen Form.
Es ist eine Hassliebe würde ich sagen also der Grundsatz,
Information des Staates sind per Default erstmal öffentlich zugänglich und nur im Ausnahmefall nicht herauszugeben der ist natürlich ganz großartig gerade in so einem Land wie Deutschland wo es so eine lange Tradition der Amtsverschwiegenheit gibt
aber wenn wir uns die Praxis anschauen dann ist es wahnsinnig frustrierend und ich glaube ganz viel was wir,
was für tun und gerade wenn wir halt zu frag den Staat dazu noch verklagt den Staat machen das machen wir teilweise auch so einer gewissen Verzweiflung raus also eine konstruktive Verzweiflung würde ich wahrscheinlich dazu sagen.
War halt einfach eine Arbeit ist wo man wahnsinnig langen Atem braucht also
jetzt z.b. die Gerichtsprozesse die wir in diesen Wochen vor vor Gericht dir vor dem Verwaltungsgericht haben in einem Monat sind wir vom Bundesverwaltungsgericht das sind alles Prozesse die haben wir 2015/2016 angestoßen und jetzt kommen die vor Gericht
und das ist natürlich in der Praxis häufig.
Nicht so einfach damit umzugehen und deswegen versuchen wir uns auch immer noch irgendwie spielerische Arten damit zu suchen damit wir das einfach ertragen können,
die Realität der Informationsfreiheit und das ist letztlich auch ein Grund warum wir jetzt dafür kämpfen dass es Transparenz Gesetze gibt,
denn die Hoffnung ist dass es das den Alltag ein bisschen einfacher macht.
Ja aber abermals noch mal jetzt rein auf das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz beziehen würde mal ganz unabhängig ist von dem neuen Ansatz
was was wären so mögliche Verbesserungen dieses Gesetzes die ist vielleicht alles ein bisschen erträglicher machen würden auch die andere Seite.
Also waren das Problem dass wir zurzeit haben das sind Betriebs und Geschäftsgeheimnisse und die kommen im Prinzip
immer rein wenn es interessant wird also gewöhnt so eine ganz klassische Frage von galistener Waffen von Handy aus oder so ist ja wo geht das Geld hin follow the money,
wo wo werden Steuergelder ausgegeben.
Wenn es darum geht geht's ja in der Regel auch um Kooperation mit Dritten also mit irgendwelchen privaten Unternehmen mit irgendwelchen Lobbyisten und da kommt man dann sehr sehr schnell in den Bereich rein wo gesagt wird.
Ja die Info an war aber die geben wenn ich raus Betriebs und Geschäftsgeheimnisse von privaten Unternehmen und da sagt sifg.
Ganz grundsätzlich das Informationsfreiheitsgesetz diese Infos sind nicht rauszugehen wenn Betriebs und Geschäftsgeheimnisse irgendwo drin sind dann war es das dann ist das Stoppschild da und das ist wahnsinnig frustrierend weil man da relativ schnell hinkommt.
Und weil es keine Abwägung gibt mit dem öffentlichen Interesse also es wird dann landen wir mal Volkswagen als Beispiel dann steht da irgendwo drin wie Volkswagen betrogen hat
und dann sagt Volkswagen mehr die Info ist aber Betriebs und Geschäftsgeheimnis wenn das an die Öffentlichkeit kommt haben wir wirtschaftliche Nachteile ja stimmt wahrscheinlich wenn rauskommt wie sie betrogen haben ist das wahrscheinlich wirtschaftlicher Nachteil,
aber dann sagt er das IFG ja mir egal komme ich an der öffnen.
Ja
Unfall.
Urheberrecht es muss ich auch noch Zahnschmerzen.
Immer immer. Wobei.
Da jetzt ganz zuversichtlich bin dass wir da über den gerichtlichen Weg jetzt gerade an an,
so eine Verbesserung der Situation kommen zumindest in unserem kleinen Nischenbereich wir haben ja wir wären ja gerade verklagt und wir verklagen auch zurück
das Bundesinstitut für Risikobewertung mit ihrem Glyphosat Gutachten dann war da man Gutachten von denen bekommen,
das ist ein Institut das angesiedelt ist beim Landwirtschaftsministerium am Gutachten von denen bekommen.
Haben das dann veröffentlicht zum Thema Glyphosat und wurden dann von denen verklagt wegen Urheberrechtsverletzung.
Was so als Prinzip natürlich ja glaube ich das sächlich schon im im Bereich Zensur ist weil hier jetzt,
das Urheberrecht eingesetzt wird um Information der Öffentlichkeit vorzuenthalten.
Ich bin aber deswegen relativ zuversichtlich dass wir das gewinnen weil wir mit diesem Urheberrecht Sachen,
relativ gut zum Europäischen Gerichtshof kommen können und der ist in der Regel der Pressefreiheit
mehr zugetan als so ein Landgericht Köln was uns jetzt in erster Instanz dazu verdonnert hat dieses Gutachten runter zu nehmen.
Und zum anderen haben wir natürlich die schöne Möglichkeit mit frag den Staat da ganz schön mit umzugehen dann jetzt ist es Grund und sieht ist man darf diese Gutachten nicht veröffentlichen aber man darf es
anfordern und muss es dann bekommen und deswegen haben jetzt knapp 40.000 Leute über falkenstation dieses Gutachten
angefragt und jetzt hat das Bundesinstitut das Problem dass sie jetzt 40.000 Anfragen beantworten müssen,
das Problem hätten sie halt auch nicht gehabt wenn sie das einfach ja uns gelassen hätten das zu veröffent.
Deichmann das ja eh so euer Hebeln über den ihr schon ganze Menge gelockert habt so diese.
Drohung mit naja Leute ihr habt eigentlich die Verpflichtung und jetzt gehen wir machen wir's halt einfach über Masse und damit gebe dem ganzen ja auch noch ein bisschen mehr Aufmerksamkeit als es euch vielleicht liebt sie ja.
Ja also das Bundesinstitut der mir auf jeden Fall eine eigene E-Mail Adresse eingerichtet,
und ich glaube die werfen gerade sehr viele Ressourcen darauf technisch überhaupt mit diesen anfragen umzugehen wir kriegen das immer mit wenn die jetzt eine Eingangsbestätigung
schicken dann schicken die immer gleichzeitig an 40000 Leute raus also die bewerfen dann unseren Server wir bewerfen deren Server.
Uns aber ganz schön zu sehen bei denen ist immer so von von 7:30 Uhr bis 18 Uhr
gehen die E-Mails raus und dann ist Feierabend und am nächsten Tag um 7:30 Uhr geht's dann weiter mit den.
Der Bachelor of ride.
Gut dann komm mir doch mal zu eurem neuen Ansatz jetzt wann was hast du gesagt wie lange arbeitet er schon dran seid.
Genau wollt ihr ein,
Transparenzgesetz haben zunächst einmal für Berlin also ist jetzt eine eine regionale Initiative warum also was habt ihr
im Sinne mit diesem Gesetz was ist der Unterschied zum Informationsfreiheitsgesetz und warum nur in Berlin.
Erstmal nur in Berlin aber dann aber dann.
Das Grundprinzip von von dem Transparenzgesetz ist dass man.
Größtenteils Informationen gar nicht mehr Anfragen muss sondern die Verwaltung dazu verpflichtet diese Informationen von sich aus zu veröffentlichen
also ein Transparenzgesetz zählt auf das sind die Informationen die der Start von sich aus veröffentlichen muss
und alle Informationen darüber hinaus die vielleicht noch gibt,
die kann man auch weiterhin Anfragen und das ist im Prinzip so die die moderne Form wie man so ein Gesetz gestaltet das haben uns ein bisschen abgeschaut aus Hamburg da können wir ja gleich noch drüber reden
und die Idee dabei ist das.
Zum einen Mann relativ einfach über Transparenz. Berlin.de diese Informationen sich anschauen und weiter verwenden darf.
Und zum anderen tatsächlich auch die,
die Verwaltung das selbst machen kann also das ist eigentlich ein ziemlicher digitalisierungs Hebel der für die Verwaltung die Idee ist das im Prinzip darüber dann die meisten.
Informationsaustausch in digital funktionieren können wenn man sich ein bisschen mit der Berliner Verwaltung auseinandergesetzt hat oder auseinandersetzen musste wahrscheinlich eher weiß man dass das
in der Regel gerade noch über Papier Akten hier und da funktioniert und das wollen wir auch ändern.
Also Transparenzgesetz ist
was ist ein bisschen EFG by default na dass man nicht erstmal alles Anfragen muss man definiert einfach bestimmte Kategorien von informations Gruppen die einfach von vorne rein offengelegt
zudem haben so die einfach da sein müssen da muss man gar nicht erst anklopfen sondern das hat dann so zu sein und das Wissen dann auch alle schon vorher.
Genau in unserem Fall ist es jetzt eine Gruppe von 31 Arten von Informationen das heißt in unserem Gesetzentwurf steht drin das z.b.
Gesetzentwürfe zu dem Zeitpunkt wo sie zur Beteiligung an die Öffentlichkeit gehen veröffentlicht werden müssen
das Treffen von Senatoren Senatoren in mit Lobbyisten veröffentlicht werden müssen
das Gutachten Studien der öffentlichen Hand veröffentlicht werden müssen dann das ist eine wirklich sehr sehr lange Liste mit.
40 Arten von Informationen das heißt wir sagen nicht dass und das Gutachten muss jetzt veröffentlicht werden sondern wir sagen wenn es ein Gutachten gibt,
dass diese Anforderungen des Gesetzes erfüllt dann muss das per Default online zu finden sein.
Und diese Liste die habt ihr quasi in Form eines konkreten Gesetzesentwurfs zusammengetragen.
Genau also wir haben vor zwei Jahren angefangen und haben
erstmal so einen ersten Aufschlag gemacht für eingesetzt haben uns dann am Hamburger Transparenzgesetz orientiert und haben das über die Zeit weiterentwickelt zum einen über öffentliche Beteiligung also man konnte den Entwurf lange kommentieren haben da viele viele Dutzend
du Kommentare von Leuten bekommen haben die eingearbeitet haben mit Juristen viel gesprochen mit Datenschutzbeauftragten der Länder
mit PolitikerInnen hier und da und haben all die Ideen setze ich dieses sogar mit eingefügt in diesem Gesetzentwurf der,
dadurch auch ganz schön umfassen geworden ist also wir sind jetzt inzwischen jetzt muss ich selbst mal nachschauen ich glaube bald 23 Paragraphen oder so.
Und da ist würde ich sagen 25125 m so die geballte Erfahrung.
Mit den Problemen der Informationsfreiheitsgesetz in auf der einen Seite und aber auch mit dem Hamburger Transparenzgesetz drinnen und die Hoffnung ist dass wir quasi mit diesem Gesetzentwurf so eine Art Idealtypus von Transparenzgesetz geschafft haben also wie
kann man so ein so ein Maximum an an Transparenz schaffen.
Unter Einhaltung der verfassungsrechtlichen Vorgaben unter Einhaltung des Datenschutzes wie kann man lässt sich geradeaus so statt Initiativen die Infos.
Zugeben dass sie damit gut arbeiten können
also wir haben z.b. relativ viel mit Leuten geredet die bei mietenvolksentscheid aktiv waren jetzt bei Deutsche Wohnen enteignen die natürlich sehr
konkrete Informationsbedarf erhaben bei mir um die Ecke wird ein Haus verkauft von von der Stadt an.
An irgend privaten Investor dann will man natürlich die die Bauvorbescheides und was was damit so zusammenhängt haben
und dieser Gesetzentwurf sagt eben all diese Informationen gerade auch in diesem Bereich mieten und wohnen die müssen eben aktiv veröffentlicht werden die sind idealerweise direkt online zu finden.
Jetzt hat jetzt ganz vergessen zu erwähnen also in Hamburg gibt's das schon ne und das gibt es jetzt auch schon seit 2012 also.
Genau und zwar ja richtig seit 2012 davor gabs,
erlischt auch das haben uns abgeschaut eine Volksinitiative in Hamburg also in Hamburg waren Chaos Computer Club mehr-demokratie Transparency International da sehr aktiv haben auch dann Gesetzentwurf geschrieben und kam da in eine
politisch sehr günstige Zeit rein,
das war nämlich zum einen in Hamburg die Zeit um den Skandal mit der Elbphilharmonie die Elbphilharmonie die 70 Millionen kosten sollte und 700 Millionen gekostet hat können wir in Berlin auch solche Sachen.
Und es war die Zeit in der die Piraten sehr stark Warnung und das hat dazu geführt dass.
Relativ schnell die Bürgerschaft also das Hamburger Parlament gesagt hat super Volksinitiative finden wir ganz toll die übernehmen wir doch einfach mal und das auch sehr besonders haben diesem Gesetzentwurf
ziemlich wortgleich mit ein paar Änderung übernommen und haben den dann verabschiedet und zwar alle Fraktionen gemeinsam also von den Linken bis zu,
AWO bei waren die Decken überhaupt drin als zumindest von den Grünen bis zur CDU alle gemeinsam DIYs Transparenzgesetz in Hamburg eingeführt
und das sieht man jetzt inzwischen auch die Akzeptanz von diesem Transparenzgesetz die ist außergewöhnlich hoch da sind tatsächlich jetzt.
Immer noch ungefähr alle Fraktionen zumindest alle demokratischen Fraktionen dahinter.
Und es gibt inzwischen auch eine Evaluation des Gesetzes nach fünf Jahren wurde die gemacht die auch das bescheinigt dass nicht nur die Öffentlichkeit
außergewöhnlich viel darüber weiß und dieses Gesetz akzeptiert sondern auch die Verwaltung selbst
also genau dass diese diese große Befürchtung oh mein Gott da werden dann irgendwie Leute überfordert Innenverwaltung alles ganz schlimm genau das zeigt sich in Hamburg das ist nicht so ist,
sondern dass im Gegenteil dies gesetzt der Verwaltung selbst dabei hilft ihre Arbeit besser zu machen weil die selbst besser an Informationen kommen,
also Mathe mit man kennt das so ein bisschen aus Berlin wenn man sich mit Leuten in der Verwaltung Unterhalt wenn da jemand versuchen Info aus einer anderen Senatsverwaltung zu bekommen dann ist das die Hölle da muss man zum eigenen Abteilungsleiter gehen
der geht zum Abteilungsleiter in der anderen simnat Verwaltung der geht dann wieder zur Sachbearbeiterin und so weiter und so weiter das ist ein Hölle nackten Info von woanders zu bekommen wenn alles direkt online ist
das sieht man in Hamburg dann ist halt einfacher für alle.
Also ist interessante Argumentationen also sozusagen gar nicht mal nur ein Feature für Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit Zusatz dem Motto jetzt gucken wir mal dem Start auf die Finger da macht sie im Staat quasi auch selbst
einfacher die Informationen zu erhalten die im für eine effektive Durchführung des Auftrags auch erforderliche.
Und da gibt's eigentlich auch wenig Widerstände.
Im ersten Schritt würde ich sagen also Transparenz finden ja immer alle super also niemand hat was gegen dem niemand hat was gegen Transparenz hat der auch.
Meistens niemand was gegen Demokratie das sind das sind so Wörter wie findet man toll und wenn die anderen wenn die anderen transparent sind ist auch super das Problem kommt immer nur an den Schritt wo man merkt achso das betrifft mich ja auch.
Also man will immer dass die anderen transparenter sind wenn es die eigene Senatsverwaltung auch transparent werden soll da will man vielleicht eine Ausnahme aber alle anderen ganz super.
Tja okay das heißt dieses Transparenzgesetz
existiert nicht nur so alles wird auch gewürdigt uns wird musst nicht am laufenden Meter in Gerichten immer wieder aufs Neue durchgesetzt werden dann kennt das ja es gibt ja auch so Gesetze ne wohl bisschen nachgeholfen werden muss
diese Auseinandersetzung habt ihr auch beim Informationsfreiheitsgesetz immer wieder also deadlock 3 läuft wo der Staat sagst du ja na klar gibt's Informationsfreiheitsgesetz aber die uns jetzt in diesem konkreten Fall ne Bundesverfassungsschutz betrifft das ja gar nicht weil keiner reich sein
und dann muss halt immer erst mal wieder nachgehakt werden.
Ja wobei also ich,
jetzt auch eine Klage gegen die Uni Hamburg laufen also es ist funktioniert natürlich nicht immer reibungslos in der Klage geht's darum
geht um die Kooperation von dem Uniklinikum mit Pharmaunternehmen
und das Uniklinikum wir nicht sagen von wem sie da Geld bekommen dann muss man da halt Klagen aber das ist eine sehr eindeutige Sache das geht jetzt halt durch die Verwaltungsgerichtsbarkeit und am Schluss wird dann Urteil warum kommen,
den sich halt die Uni Hamburg dann auch nicht entziehen kann.
Ist das jetzt eine Klage auf Basis des EFG oder eine auf Basis dieses Transparenzgesetz ist.
Das Transparenzgesetz ist.
Da will die Uni Hamburg halt nicht mitmachen aber die die kämpfen auf verlorenem Posten und dann ist das Gute eben dann hat man halt mal ein Urteil dann ist das geklärt und dann ist die Sache aber auch gegessen hoffentlich zu Minden.
Also auf eurer Webseite Volksentscheid Transparenzgesetz schreibt ihr Zielsetzung oder ein hiermit Bestimmungen zu erlei.
Steuerverschwendung vorzubeugen Vertrauen zu schaffen und Verwaltungsabläufe zu vereinfachen das sind so wesentlichen.
Ein guter la.
Ja ganz toll Vertrauen Verschwendung beenden Mitbestimmung ist richtig gute Politiker geworden.
Na danke danke.
Was ist jetzt euer eurer Marschrichtung also es steht ja schon in der URL Volksentscheid.
Transparenzgesetz. De.
Da steht jetzt erstmal dann auf der Webseite Berlin oder ist ja schon angedeutet wenn es in Berlin klappt dann wollt ihr das auch gerne auf den Rest der Bundesrepublik erweitern.
In Berlin gibt es mal los und alles soll aber über einen Volksentscheid laufen es ist ja dieses Volksentscheid
Mittel in Berlin noch gar nicht mal so oft zum Einsatz gekommen hat allerdings schon mal ne ganze Menge Welle gemacht
gerade jetzt gerade mal ich glaube das allererste Ding was mal gestartet wurde war so eine Initiative für Religionsunterricht in Berlin.
Mit Günther Jauch Herr der der war da.
Mit Günther Jauch die dann aber gescheitert ist ne die denn dann gescheitert ist und war die Entscheidung über die Verwendung des Raumes Flughafen Tempelhof dann schon die zweite.
Ich glaube schon ne.
Glaube auch ne die ja dann erfolgreich war und die Stadt,
bis heute gezwungen hat eine geplante Bebauung nicht weiterzuverfolgen,
was uns einen interessanten Raum gegeben hat in Berlin und ich denke das kann auch wie auch als
erfolgwerk Nagler je nachdem wie man das so sieht weil
Wohnungskrise wir haben ja nicht genug Platz und überhaupt und die Stadt will wachsen und jetzt hat man da so eine große Fläche in jetzt nutzen wir die nicht das Wochenende klar gut aber da hat sich das eben einfach mal das Volk geäußert gesagt dann müsste halt der andere Wege finden weil dieser Raum
ist uns eben heiligen an der Stelle hat dieser Volksentscheiden kannst du mir die Kraft entwickeln.
Und ich meinte ich nutze jedes Wochenende eigentlich nur halt nicht zum Wohnen.
Genau man kann es auch weiter argumentiert und Mädchen als er aber es geht ja jetzt nicht um Tempelhof waren es war aber schon noch mal auf so dass wir Hiekel Volksentscheid ein bisschen.
Wetter fragen weil es selbst auch nicht unbedingt so dass wir mit direkter Demokratie immer die allerbesten Erfahrungen machen,
na brexit ist vielleicht ein schönes Beispiel keine solchen Debatten hasse dann immer schnell.
Das Argument naja aber die Schweiz sie jetzt halt ja aber jeden Furz mit einem Volksentscheid auch noch mal halt auch sagen nur so ein Vehikel selber alleine hilft herzlich wenig offenbar wenn man eben nicht die passende Kultur dazu hat.
Also wenn du dann die Gesellschaft nicht gewohnt ist mit so etwas umzugehen oder ich sag mal anders wenn sie sich nicht selbst auch ein wenig herausgefordert sie
die Aufgabenstellung die da mit diesem Entscheid gestellt wird sich damit auch ausreichend zu beschäftigen,
dann droht ist ja immer schnell auch so ein populistisches Instrument zu werden.
Ja wobei ich glaube dass die Beispiele die du genannt hast nicht alle so eins-zu-eins miteinander vergleichbar sind,
was wir jetzt z.b. mit mit unserem Transparenzgesetz ja nicht machen
ist also eine Art Volksbefragung wie beim brexit also die Initiative sieht nicht so aus dass wir sagen wollt ihr ein Transparenzgesetz und wir sagen euch nicht wie es aussieht und Kreuze an ja oder nein sondern wir haben.
Ich schon jetzt dieses diesen gesamten Gesetzentwurf online für alle einsehbar das heißt wenn man wenn man will wenn man sich mit den Details auseinandersetzen kann dann kann man sich sehr genau anschauen was wo wie gemacht wird,
und ich glaube das ist ein.
Gerade so in Hinblick auf auf brexit ein starker Unterschied das sehr klar nachvollziehbar ist was in dem Fall passieren würde.
Und und und gerade beim brexit sehe ich das als als,
wahnsinnig großes Problem dass zum 1 jetzt nicht hundertprozentig klar war wird denn das überhaupt umgesetzt
weil es keine gesetzliche Verpflichtung dazu gab den brexit dann durchzuziehen und zum anderen ja überhaupt nicht klar war ja was für eine Art von brexit kommt denn dann eigentlich.
Euro das ist wahrscheinlich dann er dann doch irgendwie das Karfreitagsabkommen wo man eben ganz konkrete Gesetzesinitiative dargelegt hat Niveau
viel viel viel seid stand naja wenn ihr jetzt da zustimmt dann kommt genau das jetzt hier raus jetzt natürlich so juristische Texte zu lesen ist nicht jedermanns Sache eigentlich fast überhaupt niemandes Sache wie wollt ihr denn sicherstellen dass dieser Gesetzentwurf den ihr da jetzt abgelegt habe der ist ja
wie ist richtig verstehe jetzt zwei in einer bestimmten Form veröffentlicht aber noch nicht zwingend die finale Version oder.
Im Innen in den wesentlichen Teilen schon also wir haben
jetzt diesen gesamten Prozess in die Wege geleitet also das ist so der erste formelle Schritt wir haben den jetzt eingereicht zur Kostenschätzung dann sagt die Innenverwaltung die
Dritter irgendwie ein paar Däumchen und sagt ja das kostet soundsoviel und dann kommt das mit auf die Unterschriftenlisten wie viel die Innenverwaltung sagt dass es kosten würde.
Ist das eine zwingende Vorgabe bei solchen Sachen.
Das ist das ist immer der erste Schritt,
als erstes wird immer geschaut wie viel würde es kosten das kommt dann auf die Unterschriftenlisten so dass dann Leute die unterschreiben so die wesentlichen Punkte des Gesetzentwurf es sich anschauen können und schauen können was würde es mit dem Haushalt machen.
Und dann gibt's die 20.
Das befindet sich jetzt gerade in der Klärung.
Genau das dauert dann immer ein paar Monate das wird jetzt wahrscheinlich an alle Senatsverwaltung geschickt
wahrscheinlich auch noch ein paar Unternehmen des Landes Berlin und es wird dann jeder sagt dann bei uns kostet das soundsoviel,
die anderen sagen oder müssen wir auf Digitalisierung umschalten irgendwie kostet bei uns soundsoviel wir müssen uns Computer kaufen was weiß ich und am Schluss kommt ein Wert bei raus
und dann sagen wir wahrscheinlich wie Indikatoren von von dem Volksentscheid nee sie mal nicht so wir glauben ist viel billiger und dann kommt beide Zahlen auf diese Unterschriftenliste.
AOK oder man argumentiert halt so naja ist zwar teuer aber ist die.
Aber,
was wahrscheinlich in unserem Fall eine große Frage wird wird wie viel Geld spart man denn eigentlich ein dafür
dadurch oder was sind eigentlich die wirtschaftlichen Effekte also wenn jetzt Start-ups mit mit den offenen Daten irgendwelche Apps programmieren können und damit,
die coolsten Sachen herstellen und das dann Wirtschaftswachstum nach sich zieht dann sollte man das wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie in diese Kostenschätzung mit rein bringen aber das wird dass wir noch eine Frage die wir zu klären haben.
Und dann ist einer der schritte danach nachdem,
wir die ersten Unterschriften gesammelt haben wie ist dein verfassungsrechtlich aussieht also in Berlin ist zwischengeschaltet eine Zulässigkeitsprüfung
und da schaut sich dann der Senat an ob dieses Gesetz das davor gelegt wird mit der Verfassung von Berlin,
oder auch der bundesdeutschen Verfassung im Eingang steht oder nicht also wir könnten jetzt nicht einfach so rein schreiben.
Was weiß ich denn alle Minarette sollen entfernt werden
in Berlin das ginge eben verfassungsrechtlichen nicht und dann würde es spätestens ab dem Punkt der Senat sagen dieses dieser Gesetzentwurf der ist verfassungsrechtlich nicht zulässig und dann,
wer dann erstmal Stopp dann müssen wir entweder.
Na gut wir fordern jetzt ja zum Glück nicht dass sie Minarette entfernt werden soll aber vielleicht haben wir auch irgendwie ein Problem wo der Senat das anders sieht in dem Fall müssen wir dann vors Verfassungsgericht ziehen
und dann würde eben das Berliner Verfassungsgericht entscheiden ob das zulässig ist oder nicht das heißt wir haben in diesem ganzen Prozess auf jeden Fall
Absicherung die sicherstellen dass nicht jeder Scheiß durchkommt Automat.
So eure Marschroute
ist ja jetzt so ihr seid das jetzt noch einer finalen Klärung aber eben schon gehört dass es kommt jetzt erstmal zu dieser Kostenschätzung die dann mit reinkommt in einem gewissen Rahmen sind vielleicht auch noch ein paar last minute
die teiländerung einen dem derzeit vorgestellten Gesetzesentwurf möglich aber du siehst das
Ding sozusagen in der vor mir zu 99% schon im Zustimmung der zustimmungs fähigen Version ja.
Mir gefällts gut ja.
Okay gut Melf ich weiß nicht ob ihr noch irgendwelche internen dispute habt oder noch auf Eingaben wartet oder Kompromiss.
Nee der hat wir ham.
Formulierung da reinfahren wollte oder so ist es wie so wie es jetzt ist denkst du würdest du Abstimmung.
Genau wenn uns jetzt nicht noch ein grober Fehler irgendwo aufhält dann sollte es das jetzt sein.
Okay und starten wollt ihr damit jetzt im Sommer 2019 gibt es auch schon genaueres Datum.
Das gibt's deswegen noch nicht weil wir nicht wissen wann die Kostenschätzung kommt
wir müssen eben darauf warten dass die in Verwaltung und sagt so viel kostet es aus unserer Sicht und im Prinzip können wir ab dem Moment an loslegen und wir
gehe stark davon aus dass das bis Ende Juni passiert,
und dann würden wir Mitte Juli Anfang Juli das heißt so um den 15 Juli herum schön warm kann man schön draußen stehen und am Tempelhofer Feld Unterschriften sammeln und das dann den ganzen Sommer lang.
Und dann geht aber jetzt erstmal nur da drum.
Hat die erste Phase dieses Volksentscheids durchzuführen also wie läuft das genau ab in Berlin also ihr müsst glaube ich 20.000 Unterschriften zusammenbekommen in dieser Phase.
Genau
20000 gültige Unterschriften heißt im Prinzip von allen Leuten die wahlberechtigt sind auch zu einer Bundestagswahl und in Berlin gemeldet sind die können unterschreiben und wenn man 20000 gültige Unterschriften hat dann geht das.
Als das heißt dann formell Antrag auf Einleitung eines Volksbegehrens dann geht das als Signal an den Senat und dann hat der Senat zwei Möglichkeiten da kann einmal sagen super Idee danke dass ihr das gemacht habt wir übernehmen das.
Und,
ja das ist eine offene Frage ob der das macht oder der sagt nee wollen wir nichts mit zu tun haben nehmen wir nicht an und wenn er sagt das nehmen wir nicht an,
dann geht's weiter und dann würden wir im nächsten Schritt im Volksbegehren 170.000 Unterschriften sammeln müssen und dann mal
das dann wiederum schaffen dann geht's zum Volksentscheid zum letzten Schritt des Ganzen dann würden wir,
parallel zur Bundestagswahl 2021 tatsächlich dann über diesen Gesetzentwurf abstimmen lassen und dann Daumen hoch oder Daumen runter wenn dann die Mehrheit der Berliner sagt wir wollen das dann würde es über den Volksentscheid,
zugesetzt werden.
Also am Anfang ist es erstmal ein Volksbegehren und daraus könnte dann quasi sollte der Senat nicht schon vorher sagen alles super,
der eigentliche Volksentscheid eingeleitet werden man das wäre dann vermutlich dann mit der Bundestagswahl.
Genau und unser Name gibt es schon vor wie er wir heißen ja Volksentscheid Transparenz wir stellen uns gerade darauf ein dass wir tatsächlich diesen ganzen Weg gehen müssen und das dann bis zum Ende durchziehen.
Ja braucht er dann noch Hilfe.
Ihr braucht jetzt erstmal 20.000 Unterschriften und das aber auch erst ab Sommer also was was ist jetzt sozusagen der der Fahrt dahin was ist jetzt noch was zu tun oder muss man jetzt einfach nur noch warten bis die letzten Zettel zusammen sind und dann geht's los.
Ich bedanke mich für diese Frage und Antwort wie folgt ja es gibt eine Menge zu tun wir müssen ja diese gesamte Unterschriftensammlung noch ordentlich vorbereiten und das
ist deswegen besonders wichtig weil man eben nicht online Unterschriften sammeln darf ist es im Gesetz ganz klar vorgegeben dass das alles handschriftlich passieren muss das heißt man muss in ganz Berlin stehen.
Ständen und bei gutem Wetter Unterschriften sammeln
und das muss jetzt vorbereitet werden wir brauchen Sammlerinnen und Sammler wir brauchen Leute die mit uns die Kampagne gut machen das ist natürlich zu einem großen Teil auch eine Frage wie man Medien bedient wie man.
An die Öffentlichkeit kommuniziert um vielleicht den Senat doch zu bewegen es ein einfach zu machen und dieses Gesetz einfach zu übernehmen von sich aus.
Und ich kann mir auch vorstellen dass wir eigentlich noch so ein paar paar Sachen machen die bisher gefehlt haben bei ähnlichen Volksentscheide nicht
können wir z.b. vorstellen dass es eigentlich total sinnvoll wäre also ein paar technische Lösung für Sammlerin und Sammler bereitzustellen also wir denken gerade an der App
dies möglich macht sehr einfach zu zu schauen wo er Unterschriftenlisten ausliegen oder zuschauen wie man sich einfach vernetzen kann wie man.
Na ich habe jetzt mal.
Oder oder wo Leute sozusagen bereit sind zu unterschreiben also man muss ja nicht unbedingt immer die unterschreiber zu den Listen bringen man könnte ja auch die Listen zu die unterschreiben bringen,
also was wenn man in der App sagt zu ja hier kommt doch mal vorbei habe jetzt keinen Bock irgendwohin zu laufen und dann wird.
Oder aufzustehen.
Ja das geht auch und das wird man dann automatisch geroutet und und zueinander gefunden das wäre auch ein anderes Mal oder was mir gerade noch eingefallen dass wenn ihr sowieso im Sommer startet,
in Berlin macht man das ja dann eigentlich so da könnte man ja so der Transparenz praid mach.
Sister ich glaube solche Ideen brauchen wir genau das brauch.
Alpha Alpha 6000 Leute sozusagen zu der Demo anmelden und dann irgendwie auf Musikwagen halbnackt durch die Gegend schaukeln und nebenbei Unterschriftenlisten auslegen könnte dann auch kaputt.
Halbnackte es ist der Transparenz Volksentscheid.
Hast doch wirklich sehr gut oder.
Wobei der immer könnte auch argumentieren es gibt ja schon den CSD transparenter geht's kaum noch.
Dann sammeln wir halt da so lange Leute zurechnungsfähig sind wahrscheinlich.
Wobei darüber steht nichts im Gesetze ich glaube man ja ich glaube man darf auch betrunken oder anders wie.
Egal welcher Bewusstseinszustand man darf unterschreiben.
Er verstirbt okay aber ihr braucht auf jeden Fall Leute die diese Listen führen.
Genau die die Lust haben mit uns zusammen zu sammeln die Lust haben das mit uns.
Muss man da muss man also wie speziell registriert sein oder ist das jetzt nur eine organisations Frage bei euch.
Das na uns bescheid sagen dass man Interesse hat und dann klären wir das aber sonst also registriert gegenüber der Stadt oder so muss man eh nicht,
das ist dann vor allem in Organisationsfragen mit uns und wir wir treffen uns regelmäßig wir.
Wir wir stimmen uns gerade schon auf das ganze ein das heißt wir kommen Stimmungen wenn Leute Lust haben mit uns in Stimmung zu kommen dann sind wir da sehr offen.
Verheißungsvoll was muss denn eigentlich eingetragen werden auf diese Listen und wie werden die verifiziert.
Dero großes Thema per Hand wenn die verifiziert man muss eintragen Namen Geburtsdatum Adresse Postadresse also Meldeadresse und dann.
Die Unterschrift also die handschriftliche Unterschrift dazu und das geht dann zu den Einwohnermeldeämtern in Berlin und die schauen sich das.
Punkt für Punkt einzeln angleichen das ab mit der Datenbank und sind dann mit wochenlang beschäftigt,
also so läuft in Berlin tatsächlich die versuchen dann wahrscheinlich noch diese handschriftlichen Eintragung zu entziffern weil jemand eine Sauklaue hat und so.
Genau aber das wird dann Punkt für Punkt gemacht und
bis jetzt war immer so die die Regel das knapp 10% der Unterschriften ungültig sind das heißt setz von Anfang an auf deutlich mehr Unterschriften um da sicher zu sein und dann.
Einfach Leute in den Melder ändern.
Jetzt mal so ein Nerd fragen sich das denn in irgendeiner Form
an der Stelle auch schon so digitalisieren also wenn man jetzt nicht nur mit soll einfachen Listen daher gehen würde sondern keine Ahnung mit so einem so eine Art Bondrucker unterwegs ist
ja quasi die eigentlichen nicht handschriftlich also,
FPT Information die nicht zwingend handschriftlich erfasst werden müssen eben auch nicht handschriftlich erfasst und dann quasi eintippt in so ein Geräten bon druckt und den sich unterschreiben lässt würde das funktionieren.
Nat Antwort wir haben uns das alles schon angeschaut,
und es geht leider nicht so einfach das Problem ist dass das handschriftlich tatsächlich alles handschriftlich also selbst die Adresse handschriftlich gemacht werden muss er wir haben uns angeschaut,
wir doch vielleicht
irgendein Tool online machen können das halt die Handschrift dann erzeugt oder so ich tippe das ein und der macht dann eine handschriftliche Adresse draus wird wahrscheinlich auch nichts,
wir haben geschaut ob man sich das irgendwie ausdrucken und direkt wieder einscannen kann und uns das dann schicken darf man auch nicht weil selbst diese Listen nicht elektronisch übermittelt werden dürfen.
Name uns angeschaut können wir und wie ein Dienst machen er das automatisch ausdrucken mit der Post verschickt und so aber da sind wir dann lässt sie so weit weg von dem ursprünglichen Ding dass sich das wahrscheinlich nicht so lohnt
ich glaube das naheliegendste ist tatsächlich dieses Gesetz mal zu ändern war natürlich der Aufwand.
Um zu unterschreiben doch relativ hoch ist und ich sehe jetzt nicht warum das so sein sollte eigentlich.
Na ja gut aber ich sehe ich sehe auch den. Warum man da so eine gewisse Verlässlichkeit haben will man natürlich sonst so ein Volksentscheid potentiell natürlich auch schnell feldspar wären und man will damit gewisse Hürde haben.
Ja also das stimmt schon aber warum jetzt eine Postadresse unbedingt handschriftlich eingetragen werden muss weil sie auch nicht.
Das ist genau das hätte ich mich natürlich jetzt auch gefragt also okay ich hatte jetzt auch keinen Zweifel dass ihr das schon entspricht versucht hat ab zu klopfen ich dachte die Frage noch mal nach
gut also ihr benötigt Sammler Sammlerinnen und Sammler die bereit werden im Sommer auf dem Tempelhofer Feld zu stehen das,
lässt sich ja wahrscheinlich arrangieren.
Man kann auch an anderen schönen Stellen in Berlin stehen hauptsache man steht.
Genau hauptsache man steht oder wann wann lässt sich rupfen Braid Wagen durch die Gegend fahren sonst noch irgendwelche Unterstützung die erforderlich wäre.
Batman wahrscheinlich ganz gut ne.
Spenden sind immer gut ne wobei wir jetzt dahin mit dem Projekt.
Noch nicht so wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben haben das ist jetzt vor allem eine Frage der des Zeit Einsatzes bisher gewesen na wir haben jetzt ein Rechtsgutachten in Auftrag gegeben das hat ein bisschen was gekostet.
Ich ich glaube mit den Spenden wird es vorallem zur nächsten zur nächsten zum nächsten Schritt dann bisschen akuter.
MSG tatsächlich vor allem um um den Zeiteinsatz wenn man Lust hat auch vielleicht nur ein bisschen Zeit zu spät.
Ja okay ja Anna.
Da werde ich jetzt wieder für gescholten mir mir sagen Leute immer ich wär zu wenig um Spenden ja man kann auch Spenden jetzt sage ich es noch mal jammern.
Also,
Spenden für KL von eurer Projekte im weiteren Sinne sind immer gut angelegtes ist klar weil er natürlich die ganzen anderen Aktivitäten mit frag den Staat verklagt den Staat und ich weiß gar nicht wie viele.
Zerschlag den Staat.
Zertritt
was ja noch alles so vorhabt ich denke euch da bisher die Ideen nicht ausgegangen da kann man ganz gut davon ausgehen dass das auch weiterhin so sein wird
hier geht jetzt einfach mal ums Mitmachen und natürlich ums bekannt machen ne also
denke sich auch mal den Gesetzentwurf durchzulesen und mal zu verstehen was damit eigentlich gemeint ist das hilft dann auf jeden Fall sehr um in diesem Sommer dann interessante Gespräche auf Open-Air-Veranstaltungen zu führen.
Wo auch immer sie stattfinden mögen ja weiß nicht haben wir noch irgendetwas worauf für hinweisen sollte müsste noch irgendwas los werden.
Wo war schon mal hier sind wenn ihr euch den Gesetzentwurf durchliest Paragraph 6 Nummer
29 kann ich sehr empfehlen weil was ihr jetzt zum erstmal drin steht in dem Gesetzentwurf ist dass der Quelltext von Computerprogrammen der Verwaltung veröffentlicht werden soll,
wir hatten wir haben bisschen versucht über.
Über die Hintertür ja genau ist eine kleine Bergtour im im Gesetzentwurf darüber jetzt Open-Source sonderverwaltung hinzukriegen.
Paragraph 6 was war das.
Paraflex Nummer 29.
Ma 29.
Was ist diese lange Liste der.
Hast du da steht einfach nur Quelltext von Computerprogrammen.
Ja im ganzen Satz ist es der Veröffentlichungspflicht unterliegen und dann die lange Liste und daneben auch Quelltext von Computerprogrammen.
Grundsätzlich erstmal alle genau und dann gibt's natürlich irgendwelche Ausschlussgründe ne also wenn wenn das jetzt ein Microsoft Programm ist dann wird wahrscheinlich Urheberrecht dagegen stehen.
Aber grundsätzlich genau der Grundsatz ist das erstmal der gesamte Quelltext von einem Computerprogramm veröffentlicht.
Luca du gehst mit.
Banane dann will ich sagen wir mal den Deckel drauf hier vielen Dank für die Auskunft.
Danke.
Unterm Zeh transparent.
Man muss es selbst leben.
Genauer muss es selbst Leben erlebt dass wir lieben das auch ja du bist sagen Mama Deckel drauf das war
das Logbuch Netzpolitik Spezial Nummer 299 wir haben es geschafft rechtzeitig hier zur 300 dann auch die die Zahlenreihe komplett erhalten und ja
danke Anna danke fürs Zuhören ich sag tschüss und bis bald.